avant qu'on commence tu as une assurance
tu es bien couvert ça rembourse les
frais d' il y un hôpital dans le coin il
est loinir 25
[Musique]
minutes GI ça va
all alors comme ça vous aimez vous
battre et vous gagnez jamais de vra
gagn
vous êtes pas à l'hôtel ici l'ami je
pars je m'en
vais un ami m'a conseillé de venir te
voir je tiens un road house un de ces
bars en bord de
route depuis un moment ça attire une
mauvaise clientèle je te Peris bien vu
l'état de ta caisse tu en a grave besoin
j'adore ma caisse
réfléchis-y
je sais qui tu es toi hwood Dalton je
suis un de tes fans ce type cache un
couteau sous sa chemise tu recul d'un
pas et tu lui mets immédiatement une
droite tu vas y
arriver parle-moi de ceur il est tout
cool tout gentil on croirait ma ou je
sais pas qui puis d'un seul coup il met
une
vraé c'est un gars intéressant au
final brand fait tout pour que le r
ferme il veut construire une saloperie
d'hôtel pour des gros coniches
il faut que je vous avertisse ici les
gens règl les conflits à leur
manière salut les filles je vois qu'il y
a une fête à tout casser ce
soir j'ai un conseil pour toi laisse
jamais quelqu'un t'approcher d'I
pr laisse-moi deviner tu vas menacer
pour me pousser à quitter la
ville j'ai la nette impression qu'on
peut pas te faire peur
quand Nox est sur le coup c'est que
c'est réglé mon petit
biquet c'est dur de me mettre en colère
mais quand je le suis j'ai aucune
retenue les gens ont l'air un peu
agressif dans le
coin et lui c'est un de vos amis non je
suis juste pte le
bras